welcome to this video a new part of the
calculation and tactic series yeah this
is again a video where I'm just going to
look at one position one position where
calculation and tactics play the
dominant role and with good calculation
in good term good vision and imagination
widen this position would have been able
to get to win the game in this game
played between harikrishna playing white
and Votto Keaton playing black here this
white smooth and in fact harikrishna
in the actual game did not spot what is
possible here I think if you get this
position as a as a tactical puzzle like
here it is maybe more likely that you
will yeah that you will actually spot
what's possible in an in a game where
you don't know that there is something
concrete going on this is even more more
difficult okay so if you want to look
for yourself and I encourage you to do
so you might as well pause the video and
have a look what I can point out is of
course that it's um it's about the f5
pawn yeah in a way this is the target
that white has already M yeah set sides
on with the knight on edge for the
bishop on c2 the rook is active but what
exactly can you do concrete moves okay
I'm going to give you them and I think
amazing solution to this puzzle now last
chance to pause the video
okay YTM he played 92 by the way if we
just want to check what he did he played
this move which looks like yeah it said
the the strategic means yeah I'm putting
putting a knight here this kind of idea
but he
a tactical strike and the track tickle
strike is amazingly enough Bishop takes
and five okay so maybe a move that that
is considered by many many people look
at the position but the big issue is of
course we need to look at the the
capture black really has no alternative
black takes and what is the point of all
of that if you just take on f5 black
recaptures and we have no promising
continuation but what about this look at
form hmm
now we are quite clearly threatening to
take on f5 with the rook and wins yeah
we are winning material then yeah what
responses does black have he needs to
move the king that's pretty much clear
so if we start with this we have a
pretty simple move that I guess this is
within the abilities of most players to
see g-form picking up a piece due to the
pin on their phone however what about
this move this is the real problem if
you look at this now we yeah we can take
on f5 now but if we do that that's just
putting on the board black as a piece up
so we don't really regain a piece now by
grabbing on f5 but we have all kinds of
pieces hanging our Knight hang the rook
hangs so this looks like a failure what
is what should why do now in fact the
big and amazing point of the whole
combination is that white now has the
great move g3 and this is one of those
moves that you can yeah give two
exclamation marks with a clear
conscience especially well actually
Bishop f5
the two exclamation mark move as it only
makes sense in connection with g3 yeah
what is this g3 it covers the night and
it covers the rook so there's nothing
hanging anymore but what exactly is the
threat if you look at it again here the
threat in fact is and this is the
amazing point the threat that white has
is white threatens to capture on f5 and
then play ninety form and this regains
the peace with an extra form to boot so
for example if black plays a means
96 for example we're just going to take
here black recaptures and then this
check we have an absolute the amazing
situation here where two Knights
completely dominate king and rook yeah
black King has to move and then we are
just going to take the rook and we get
to an endgame now where we are yeah I
guess winning two knights on both sides
and the extra pawn is just very close to
a win so it always about winning one
pawn but the amazing thing and what
makes this really remarkable position is
that this silent move g3 really sets up
this rook takes a five threat getting it
back it's an absolutely amazing
situation with those two Knights
dominating the whole the whole
procedures him black is just losing this
piece back and will remain a pawn down
probably with the lost and game this was
it was exceptionally difficult to see
and my congratulations to to those of
you who have actually seen this
beforehand yeah I wanted to share this
because it's it's really something yeah
out of the ordinary this kind of
situation that we see here on the board
where black has no way to avoid this
rook takes a fire threat yeah I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching